now guys this is a very different song
b-movie isn't isn't it that's not just a
zombie movie is that part of the appeal
for it when you got involved yes I'm mad
I don't I don't really I'm not attracted
in zombie movies in general and so I
didn't know what kind of movie it was
when I started reading the script and
yes I'm twice it's great zombie movie
it's a you know it's like in most Sami
movies are with a hero that has a
machete and some grenades that movies
happening in this but instead of being
with those characters you're like seven
doors down at Danes house where he's
like almost in a strange Woody Allen
film it's very relationship driven which
most zombie movies aren't so much a
heartfelt usually just trying to stay
alive
exactly now you guys are part of a
fantastic cast what was it like working
with people that will bury john c reilly
equals to a money Shannon and Dane yeah
so Heinz I said put you guys up I
thought that it was an absolute honor
truly so many of my favorite actors are
in this movie and I'm so honored to be a
part of it it was really fun he you know
when we wouldn't be weren't shooting
ready for the lights or something
everybody just sat around in the living
room and told stories until jokes was
really great and it's coming up for you
now there's gonna be more Criminal Minds
more Suburgatory as well what can we
expect from each of those mm-hm
take it away well on Suburgatory and you
know what the crossover we're doing
across really solved
you